so Jenna in Game of Thrones yeah you do
a lot of horse acting oh I'm I'm an
alright also when they taught me to ride
a horse but if we did have a scene where
it was some very very fatty horse and it
wouldn't go oh whatever the technical
term for making a horse go a little
squeeze but yeah well I wouldn't with a
kick it wouldn't go but anyway but all
the way up well Alfie and I were doing
our lines it's a scene where we get
quite was a Babson yeah well honey oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and that was
one of my audition scenes which was
quite interesting we're not anyone but I
thought that the audition scene was the
other way around
yes it was the other way around so in
the actual scene it was Alfie working
away on me but in the audition my mother
is watching working away and your mother
not watch came across she had she has
something she doesn't ask about anyone
change any means you talking about
healthy working around you might be
quite
I remember being English in the original
scripts it was my character and it said
Yara and my character is worrying his
[__] he viewed the hub on Sara with some
sort of bucket and Gemma more good but
she is worrying it and I obviously sort
of understood that to be you know
working away back there but anyways
thanks and I had to do that in my
audition on a chair sort of looking
straight ahead very very dramatically
with just one casting director in a room
in a very sort of ashamed cameraman oh
that's not how you do it
[Laughter]
[Music]